merica Captain America the First Avenger
I'm sure this movie has a subtitle the
First Avenger so other parts of the
world can give a [ __ ] and because it
doesn't feature Big Macs Bon Jovi
MacGyver rest assured if it did feature
Big Macs Bon Jovi and MacGyver it was
just been called Captain America because
that is how we roll now I think a lot
was riding on Captain America the First
Avenger because you know it's the First
Avenger if this movie failed the whole
Avengers thing that they're going for
would kind of feel like it was built on
bricks of [ __ ] so Captain America is the
story of Steve Rogers played by Chris
Evans and I got to say he is so absurdly
skinny I saw it in the trailers and I
was really impressed in the trailers how
we look but when you see it on screen
you're like that's impossible
he looks like Chris Evans if he had AIDS
and they superimposed his face on like
golems body
he looks absurdly sickly and this is
world war two and there are two kinds of
people in the world
Americans and marek ants yeah in the
world makes sense
Steve Rogers is clearly that first one
this kid is so patriotic he just wants
to get out there and serve his country
and actually thought that was really
cool to see I mean these days you don't
see that these days people are like yeah
I know you're paying for four years of
college but no thank you but him he's
like no I just want to go out there and
do good so I really like Steve Rogers
attitude he's just a good guy which is
why Stanley Tucci is like that's the guy
we want for the whole super-soldier
experiment thing and so he becomes the
Super Soldier Captain America and after
that they're like all right now what do
we do with them all right we'll just
make him a propaganda piece which is
funny and I like that they did that
because that's why Captain America was
created same with Superman country
morale cuz nothing speaks American
morale like an alien from Krypton which
is why we got Captain America it's a lot
of point he's like you know what enough
of this [ __ ] I'm going in there and I'm
doing some good the main bad guy in the
movies the Red Skull played by Hugo
Weaving and Hugo Weaving was like born
to play the Red Skull I always thought
the guy looked like a skeleton anyway
and he plays a good villain we all know
that so it was it was perfect
I thought the Red Skull was like some
Hitler enthusiast or some it's not
really like that he just hates
absolutely everything he's one of those
old-school comic book villains who just
wants to destroy everything I know
little thanks Hugo Weaving totally
killed his red skull now when going into
these Avengers tie-in movies I always
forget that they tie in so I'm watching
Captain America and I'm like holy [ __ ]
look at that it ties in with orbit which
I really like seeing I like this whole
intricate web of interconnect
movies that Marvel's doing got to give
him props for that there was a lot of
buildup diamond I like seeing when he
was skinny and I like seeing how you
know it shows the quality of his
character then it becomes a
super-soldier but he's a propaganda
piece so he's still not really doing
anything in war then he gets out into
battle and you know the scenes that
showed in the trailer so he busts in the
door and starts blasting people yeah
they like montage through that you get
the feeling he goes out in a few battles
but it's all like montage montage with
no 80's music that no you can't do that
however there were some action scenes in
this movie that we're just straight-up
awesome that shield is a great weapon I
mean I knew we threw it you know I know
the whole concept of the shield but when
you see it like bounce off of someone's
chin and make that ping sound you're
just like I want that shield and there
were some action scenes that reminded me
of a video game raid like not MMO raid
more like Unreal Tournament raid you got
a bunch of soldiers fighting then one
guy gets in the vehicle and the other
guy gets on the fifty Cal on the top and
he's just blasting people while the
other guys driving through the base I
was like yeah we got our Unreal
Tournament action sequence check and
there is one scene that I kid you not is
the train scene from uncharted 2
verbatim like it's the same there in the
mountains they're advancing the Train
wall it's moving you got the big guys in
armor that are coming after them that
are like impossible to kill I'm telling
you it was uncharted 2 a lot of the
scenes though you could tell they use
special effects you know that artificial
sunlight green screen kind of effect you
get when you're like on a green screen
usually happens when they try to
recreate 1940-something on a green
screen just looks like artificial
sunlight like Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull or something quite a few scenes
you noticed that going on but it's not
like sky captain in the world of
tomorrow or anything like that so it
kind of annoys you but you kind of roll
with it other scenes when he's thrown
people you can tell they're on strings
and whatnot so that kind of looks fake
but then he'll throw the shield and
bounce it off someone's face you're like
I forgot about the strings and you saw
him in the trailer Howard Starks in it
Tony Stark's dad and it's funny because
samuel l.jackson was saying to Tony
Stark and Iron Man - he was like remind
me of him you know your father I was
just like I don't see it I saw the 70
stock footage he does not remind me of
Howard Stark in the lease but in Captain
America Howard Starks young he's in his
prime and I'm like yeah he reminds me a
Tony Stark
so I really like the character Steve
Rogers probably more than any character
I've liked since Tony Stark which is
funny because they're so different
they're like absolutely different
they're nothing alike not at all the
movie was cool it was fun the pacing was
a little off I felt in a lot of scenes I
don't know if it was an action-packed
movie or a movie that took a while to
get going probably both mixed in among
itself but it's still worth checking out
and I'm gonna buy it on blu-ray
so the Avengers set up movies are out
now so which one's your favorite Iron
Man
one Incredible Hulk Iron Man 2 Thor
Captain America comment below let me
know but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more America because I
can